that's the end of that's the end of the
planet yeah yes yeah do you think that
it would probably garner a good like you
know amount of people people would watch
it yeah I wouldn't I'll tell you what I
didn't I didn't look member when those
celebrity photos leaked and everything
which other oh yeah I don't look at
those
cuz that's that's [ __ ] up I also that
Chinese guy that Chinese there was a
Chinese guy who answered an ad to do
this short film in Canada yeah about
this right and so he shows up at all I
want to be yeah at all before me
that's sad they didn't get the part
anyway you got tied up and some gay dude
just a toe Luka Magnotta yeah Luka
Magnotta a them on camera and people
around the world watched it live yeah
I would watch out I know but what is I
mean what does that do to you it gives
you an incredible amount of like PTSD or
some variant of that I think it really
honestly I don't think it does that much
I think that people watch that and then
they're like I think we're so [ __ ] up
that we would watch it and then be like
then go to sleep in the next morning we
would get up and go to work and then go
to the grocery store and you don't think
it does some like underlying type of
like I don't really think so
maybe I'm just like yeah maybe I'm a
sociopath but like because you can't
even watch you don't even watch like you
can't watch like any kind of videos that
are dead like the motorcyclist send me
[ __ ] sometimes I'm like I can't watch
that [ __ ] yeah babies and [ __ ] yeah he
loves tragedy porn your favorite thing
what's that it's it's just a desire to
always see like babies in Syria and then
you know crying about it at that moment
like he likes to cry about it
Wow yeah I mean like when the Korean
ferry sank
you know CNN had this like video of like
parents watch looking at their like
teenage kids that died in this ferry and
then you could hear them through the
tent crying and I watched that video
like a hundred times so I could cry too
but why because I don't even want to
hear you talk about it no because I want
to cry I feel dead inside that you feel
like you need to pull from these things
to feel I feel like I am I know I'll be
honest with you I think I am Denon
I know what you you know why you're dead
inside
why because you [ __ ] either the diner
finish and then rush off you don't think
you're jaded of things like yeah I do
but but I'm talking about like jaded in
a conversation like you know we do
stand-up and we do what we do and we're
[ __ ] failing and people are booing at
us and [ __ ] yeah and we you know
sometimes we're [ __ ] doing great and
whatever but like that means that when
I'm in a party I don't want to talk to
somebody about their [ __ ] kid yeah
but that's all that means
yeah but because like oh I I go up on
stage and I [ __ ] have 400 people to
2,000 people a night waiting on me yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and you want to have
a conversation yeah Calvin and I talked
about this a lot of here's that here's
that it's interesting you say that
because it's like I was thinking the
other day like I remember when I was an
open mic or in San Diego and I remember
like going up like getting on a show and
even if there was like five ten people
in audience and if I did even remotely
well it was a kind of euphoria yeah that
it's it's not tangible you can't know is
if you still feel that you for you at
this level well I I think yeah there are
moments where I do yeah for sure
definitely it's more of a thoughtful
poignant moment though rather than a
this new kind of but it's not the
feeling that you have it's not this is
the same rush you felt nowhere initially
starting when you first started right
and you like God like you know we used
to do that dear bit it was a hilarious
bed right you would crush with that or
that German bit they used to do right
and you there's no way that you feel
that anymore I guess I don't yeah I
guess I'd have to think you know I mean
because here you here let me just I'm
gonna be honest with you I well I know
the kind of places that you play right
you play theatres right sometimes you'll
do a club I'll notice but like a lot of
times you'll do a theater and you'll
sell it out of 1,500 seats or whatever
mind me and you're backstage I play
theaters before not myself but like I've
been on and it shows and um and I know
the feeling of like the deadness in sign
right because you know you're up and
you're doing well like I've done you did
oddball I did I've done
I used to do that one in San Jose all
the time right a lot of people but you
the feeling that you once had right it's
[ __ ] gone it's less less less it's
not gone right
but yeah it's like chasing if you're
chasing the feeling it's like yeah drugs
yeah like drugs so the rush now is your
actual just baseline what used to be the
rush is now just your baseline yep and
if you don't hit that baseline then it's
disappointment right
[Music]